what's up everyone what's up welcome to
another episode of rent cafe right here
at Anime uproar episode 34 and in this
one we're gonna be talking about our
first impressions for the summer 2017
anime season and joining me today we got
some awesome guests we got Jojo talks
too much what's up man hey man how's it
going
how are you great Joel Joe is back we
got some why are you being so subtle
[Music]
anime recon is here as well
what's up entering an American gnosis
seasonal anime so here hashtag recon Oh
Pico hashtag havoc no pico boys yes love
it he embraces all of it and that's why
we love them yeah
your first gets pissed off about those
nicknames and then I think you know what
I don't [ __ ] care I'm used to it
whatever you want love it great great
attitude to have you don't let no one no
one bother you yeah also joining us is
Sol Mok I feel he's also well versed in
terms of seasonal anime I know we've
been watching them on discord together
some of them and discussing them so
what's up Sol yeah hey guys yeah me
again back again yep we're gonna talk
about this summer season and yeah it's
cool nice nice and by the way if you
don't know if you new to the channel and
you're just joining us and you're like
what is this what's happening why am i
seeing these faces this is a weekly
anime podcast that we do on this channel
talking about all sorts of anime stuff
every Thursday 5 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time
we have other youtubers as guests and
other interesting and you know informed
well-informed people as guests and then
we discuss live in the chat with you
guys have a good time try to address as
many comments as we can
that kind of stuff welcome everyone in
the chat I see a lot of people are there
already and yeah this is gonna be a fun
one I have my list of all the seasonal
anime I watched a bunch of the first
episodes at least first and seconds to
get some good first impressions but in
the meantime who wants to
start off their first impressions of the
season in general and some of the anime
you liked and didn't like I purposely
went out when you asked I was like oh
[ __ ] I haven't watched almost anything
yet
so I saw like the first episode of
everything and then right after that I
got asked like you have to watch
everything so is like fine so I watched
the first episode of like a buncha shows
I don't wanna say like all of them but a
huge chunk of them and I think it's fine
I'm not usually an edgy guy I leave that
to recon that's usually usually not my
thing
but uh how'd you mention nogales great
cuz I I was for some reason read the
manga on that so I enjoyed that one they
kind of jump it into things they haven't
liked that in the manga they shouldn't
have done but that's fine so I like that
all room is great
token gate open katsu Gehrke token ranbu
fantastic love that and I like a Yama
that's a good show too but those are
just quickies thoughts yo guys it's
NeoGeo in the chad i think he's been
here since we were like 1000 subs or
something he's been here a long time
what's up yeah thanks Jojo for your
insight and yeah guys thank you for all
the support we were 37 thousand
subscribers now which is nuts when you
think about this is all real people like
it just sounds like a number but this is
all real people who actually bother to
subscribe to this channel and want to
see more or a content which it's such an
honor thank you so much okay next up
next up a recon I know you're really
excited to talk about this yeah let me
know what your overall thoughts are and
what are some of the standout anime for
you and by the way Jojo I think I mean I
have to give that Hajime nogal show a
shot I haven't watched it yet but recom
loves it now use it so for me to
recommend yeah like if it was just recap
like yeah sure buddy but if you say it
I'm going to say this straight up but
the comedy is this the comedy of this
season for me at least has to be Hajime
to no guile but yes there is a
huge competitor today a new enemy came
out cold gamers ah yes I was
it's so [ __ ] funny I'm saying this
right now but this anime is gonna be a
competitor against hajimete oh no God
because I laughed so hard the big
character is so [ __ ] like he's so
awkward that I love him so much so it's
about gamers is about a club at school
specifically for people who love gaming
and and what they do over there is play
a lot of games were actually some gaming
references like guilty guilty guilty
wars I think it's called guilty gears
little guilty wars and there was also
some counter strike count csgo reference
over there which I play csgo myself and
I loved it so much but the main
character is so awkward and I loved him
so much so I I definitely recommend it
and has we need to admit you know gal
I've watched the first episode and a lot
of people say it is so close like the
border of hunt I'm bored of hentai yeah
yeah it's real it's real close but the
censorship though it's like I'm like
what the heart-shaped censorship and in
his in the main character's dream Wendy
she was on top of him that yet at the
hand of the god appeared from the
Rockies what I like that they even say
like I was expecting that honestly oh
but those two are definitely great
comedy series I highly recommend you all
to watch soul maka what about you what
are your thoughts well the series that
stand out for me so far this summer
season is kakigori
the gambling high school one koi - so
which is like romance drama high school
setting again obviously then as the
there's the maiden abyss
that's why I love it I got a guy into
the mango of that so I know that like
Danny is kind of like skipped a bit of
like the explaining at the beginning and
just like he's jumped into the action so
it should be good and I'm guessing the
explanations will come as the journey
progresses you know token ranbu yeah
that looks good that looks like well Fei
apocrypha should have looked like that
it doesn't impress me and what I've
heard of the story I'm still I'm not
confident in it so at the moment I'm
giving it a Miss I'm just gonna like
like finish and then find out like like
overall what it was like and whether or
not it's worth investing my time in
that's fair yeah there was that is sekai
if I was small no no no no cafe thing
that looks I don't know like it'd be
kind of interesting seems more like a
kind of sweet story I guess of the the
homeless girl who gets hired by the cafe
so I'm gonna give that a couple more
episodes before I make up my mind on not
really surprised me yeah yeah yeah they
expect it to be like that lies yummy I
was expecting this to be like you know a
set establishment already and then like
loads of odd different figures coming to
this place and you know some kind of
comedy growing up from the interactions
you know that happened and stuff but the
first episode just seemed to focus on
this like down and out demon girl kind
of thing yeah I mean so it was yeah he's
trying to be a bit more sentimental know
the Bowie
Yokoso is good as well do like that Wow
I enjoyed the manga so I'm invested in
the anime oh yeah I always read manga
stuff Lee Kappa key danchi aryama the
one with the football guy
heightened playing football that's what
it is
I love the latest episode where everyone
wanted to smell is [ __ ] everybody
coming fellas towels smell so good yeah
yeah that's only nuts that's all right I
mean no sound bits like in the first
episode where I expected more humor like
you know when he finally got himself
dirty to score that goal I was expecting
him like to freak out you know in like a
real good question but he didn't do that
and you just thought well you know it's
cool so that kind of like you plated it
a bit for me but you know because he
said he didn't mind if I was like the
last few minutes of the game I wouldn't
mind getting dirty I was pretty
surprised I wasn't like I like that they
treat him like this is how like like a
clean freak would genuinely be like they
could they have fun with him but they
don't make fun of him which I thought
was cool I'm a bit of a germaphobe
myself actuality it plays off itself and
that's just it it's primarily a
psychological based thing and it's all
about how you approach it so I mean
that's just it like like soul I was
expected in the have more fun with it in
terms of him thinking out reacting
around people cuz that's kind of one of
the things with it but they do a little
bit but not so much but hopefully as the
show goes on they'll get more into that
then yeah because that's the thing is
they went on about it so much at the
beginning I constantly like droning and
TE he wants to be clean he wants to be
clean everything has to be clean it has
to be supposed has to clean it has to be
clean and then it gets messy and nothing
happens you know I know I mean my
relaxing show though where I'm like this
is just the show I unwind - yeah yeah
you should be funny then that's fine
yeah you don't need to think too much
about but you can still enjoy them right
but they're not it doesn't think
sometimes you know anime critics they're
like everything has to be a masterpiece
kind of thing where it doesn't you can
enjoy an anime without it being a
masterpiece I just want to address a few
people in the chat we had Santiago over
there saying why his math in three
months we're gonna hit 100k subscribers
I'm sorry to break it to you man there's
no such thing as math on YouTube YouTube
this come
pletely you never know anything do you
do caste memes said that he made 30,000
fake accounts to subscribe I commend
your commitment man that is amazing
thank you we got snow early Luna rate
this imperialist opinions creep
Ellen is in here I saw elfs Josh swag
master keeps saying hey I'm swag master
from the discord I know that's you have
the same name and I know you were the
guy from the discord and by the way guys
if you want to join our discord that's
where we chat on a daily basis and
organize things like twitch streams and
stuff I kind of party streams link in
the description to that cyanide I want
to weigh in with you now I know you
haven't had a chance you were having
some audio issues so you know what are
your first impressions of the season in
general before we get too much into
individual anime well then um you know I
recently been rather busy but I was able
to make some time I was like I got to do
this could make time gonna watch them
show those watch some shows I enjoyed
watch some shows that you know I beat
your since he really going watch some
shows that I absolutely detested so a
little bit of variety um I gotta say for
a moment going back to the germaphobe
guy if they really wanted to strike a
chord be realistic and make a comedy
have them get dirty and then do like the
internal monologue thing we're sitting
there going exposed to that and then
that would also kind of give a humorous
moment where he's he's calm on the
outside but in the inside he is just
losing it that would have been great
that phone is you gotta you gotta like
keep appearances right yeah in the chat
I noticed you man we got Emilia shot
those Haru mega makkal not is in the
chat world bro is in the chat Ino is in
the chat crazy-crazy turn out some very
cool peeps that I personally know and
appreciate some guys and gals um the
only other two that really stood out for
me the season as well though is Vatican
kosecki I kind of really the the new
Netflix show of Castlevania this
because I wanted to count try he's God
season sorry it wasn't that good it was
pretty [ __ ] Castlevania
alright you didn't like Castlevania
how could anyone like it it's amazing
how could you not hate won't seem very
polarized with a classic Castlevania cuz
I've met other people who dislike it as
well and it was I didn't like it did you
guys play the game it wasn't 20 no wait
why what's wrong with it okay
Castlevania it's not an anime it's the
North American anime inspired show but I
will just tell you why it's terrible
okay first of all historically it's a
joke you have Catholic priests running
things in Romania which was always
historic the Orthodox Christian I know
I'm Orthodox Christian so it's complete
nonsense that's what's killing you there
is no mention of the Turks
there is no mention of the Turks in
Malaysia in 1400s like what a joke that
there's a vampire man who summons hell
absolutely not about a vampire
Castlevania creates a vampire figure who
is Saul Opie for absolutely no reason or
explanation he has godlike powers he can
manifest destroy entire cities with
flames summon demons teleport like if
it's so ridiculous man course he's the
last boss it's a lately open completely
open no explanation why he's ope and
don't get me started on the animation
the facial expression animation in this
show is so bad like shows into early 90s
and 80s were better than this shows
facial expression animation but while I
think that there's some cool characters
of potential like alucard and Trevor I
feel like overall it was just like I no
idea why people are hyped for this show
it was not good guys I I really loved
this show but like I grew up playing
Castlevania I'm like yeah Trevor like
you got Trevor you got I always called
her Sipho but apparently she's CIPA or
whatever they call her in this it like
like to me I'm like yes good I like all
these characters it's literally like
it's the
game which i think is cool except they
left out [ __ ] what's-his-face that
camera his name but he's like the pirate
thief guy oh yeah yeah him I can't for
the life of me remember his name right
now but he's cool and I don't know I
like that show I feel like this could be
an episode of its own what we love and
eight of Castlevania yeah that's the
thing like you see I only played the
game so I'm just like uh you know so
from that good yeah person looking into
it which I think makes me more objective
because they didn't go into a not one
you liked it but I just was not
impressed at all that's fair like I
think I think this show heavily relied
on like y'all remember Castlevania right
and if you're like no you're like what
the hell's going on why is dry cuz in
those games it also doesn't make like
Dracula's like a vampire right but he
can also like she commands death itself
and Frankenstein's monster and the mummy
and like all these other creatures and
they don't really explain how like so
I'll give like it's just cuz I've played
those games I like it I think the story
is fun mainly because it's written by
Warren Ellis who I love so but I also
understand he can be real hit and miss
sometimes I understand why people might
not like it but I [ __ ] I loved it
oh yeah I mean that was always the thing
is that it's just you know Dracula was
up to no good and you were part of a
lineage of vampire hunters you have to
stop him and you were fighting these
mythical creatures as well so well and
Trevor had nope like none of them had
personality no no no character no
personality yeah I always imagined
Trevor to be like Captain America for
some reason he was like a real like it
was a real good guy and he's gonna go
stop the bad guy like you know like he's
a real like true hero and this he's like
a [ __ ] drunk [ __ ] I love him in
this way better than what I thought he
was yeah the thing that I don't
understand is also he his wife gets down
at the stake that was for trying to help
people on using science because she
dedicates her life to helping people and
then he's like well I'm gonna commit
genocide against these people now he
differed like that my wife the memory of
my wife I wish
people she wanted to help like it's just
such bad writing like maybe it's fun for
you but it's terrible writing guys if
you killed my wife and my wife was a
doctor I would kill you cuz it's like
I'd like I'm gonna pull all the humanity
he doesn't he doesn't yeah that's the
thing he doesn't kill the necessarily go
after the guys that are responsible dumb
Catholic Church in Romania and the 1400s
clearly he goes out everyone innocent
people which is so stupid because his
wife too was innocent and that's the
whole point so this guy must be some
kind of complete [ __ ] who somehow is
this great godlike part where all this
all these inventions in his home that we
don't know anything about that doesn't
know but in that's why I look hard
wisdom and the so yeah Alucard tried to
try to stop him and yeah I like this
this show makes no sense father and I
just
father the show makes and father is like
no now you're going to sleep until the
fourth episode exactly the character
everybody wants to see you go away that
said that introduction was [ __ ]
awesome it was yeah I did I did like
that yeah I like I like ever battle I
thought that was highlight of the show
with for me but like again that's the
whole season those four episodes I'm
just at the end of the fourth episode
gets kind of interesting for me well it
was originally supposed to be a movie
like this was they wrote this and I
think like 2007 it was supposed to be a
movie and as much as I liked the show
you can tell like you can tell that
they've retooled this let me make sense
cuz yeah that's just it we haven't heard
from Castlevania in quite a while
Konami is not doing anything with it so
yeah it makes sense that it would have
been around that time I'm happy Konami
is not doing anything people were going
off-topic yeah yeah
Castlevania is not part of this summer
animate 2017 so okay well you could
expect from rad cafe is great
discussions we were the
yeah but well I wanted to get my
Castlevania rantin because some people
told me you want to see this and I was
like okay and it's the god let's just
agree on this [ __ ] Castlevania no gold
to summer animate 2017 let's talk about
see how suck about anyway we can't say
let's talk about Qi
anime I checked out I still need to
check out some of the ones you mentioned
like the nogal thing yeah apparently
it's a lot of it's a lot of fanservice
so I don't mind that as long as it's not
all the fanservice actually just there
is Ollie with big poke okay big ass huge
adamak you need to know this in advance
uh the protagonist friends are basically
lolly Khan's they have an obsession with
little girls okay well okay no no but
okay
the more you do anything with the dough
but they don't think about it though so
if they do that if they do this
correctly the manga has like actual
romance and the characters get to felt
like they start off real 2d and they
become actual characters as the manga
goes on I usually don't like edgy but
this story kind of got yeah I'll check
it out but if I feel like I'm I'm like
like a fit mate even after watching it
I'm not gonna keep watching it that's
fine totally bail if it's if it's rings
yeah you know completely unnecessary
lollies fade a Apocrypha everyone on
this show I feel is going to be ruined
completely like I feel like it's a good
setup but I very much have the feeling
that it's gonna end up being crap
because they have not one not two but
three heroes somehow becoming a lollies
for absolutely no reason which to me
just says they're pandering this charge
is gonna be about pandering to otaku's
there's not gonna be any substance to it
and while I think that Jean is an
interesting character everyone else
seems pretty 2d to me your classic
archetypes
so I don't know man i-i'll keep watching
it but I'm I'm fearful I do like the
concept of fate Epoque
it's very interesting in me it's not the
same as fate fate zero it's not like
only it's a team based it's a it's a
team based battle it's between the ready
action the black faction this is this is
different we haven't seen this before so
that's what's really interesting this
still the competition is not here yet
but I guarantee you we will be getting a
lot of action but you guys notice that
Jack of the Ripper is actually a [ __ ]
Molly yes good episode
no castor aka Shakespeare he said he was
talking about Jack the Ripper and we
just got a scene where we see a lolly
girl walking down the alleyway with
blood on her mouth I was like is that
really Jack that's okay why do we is
anyone going to is anyone going to
reference the fact that Jack the
Ripper's supposed to be a great
historical hero like what the hell is
happening how is he many people are
complaining the fact that a-1 pictures
are doing fate Apocrypha they don't like
that they don't want anyone pictures
yeah they didn't want anyone pictures to
animate Fayette Apocrypha so that's why
people are disappointed many think it
will be a disappointing it's gonna be
trashed gonna be a letdown however I do
have potential I do have faith in it I
think it's gonna be good you have to
wait for it don't you know you thought a
bull generally does it and I get people
whining into it but that's the thing is
they don't need to cover everything fate
related it's fine if letter excuse
branched out but it is gonna be
interesting
obviously of course type-moon is very
big with the Fate universe bowing
gender-bending things essentially to
where it's like oh well you see history
is dictated that they're supposed to be
this but did you know that isn't
actually the case because I mean
obviously history's influenced by man
what's crazy stories oh yeah so that's
it no it's messed up the wig light I
mean if you're looking at like things
like say like a a few in legend and
stuff you know like oh yeah look at that
end
try to attach that to the sex that the
characters have Charlemagne's paladin is
like a little girl or something are you
kidding me yeah I like saber I dig I'm
fine with with with them saying was not
King Arthur was a girl I'm like okay
that's a little bit weird but I like
saber so it's fine because they made
saber a character okay yeah he's
interesting but Jack the Ripper the
lolly is [ __ ] weird
that's really not okay and then like
gender-bending you can only shatter
bread like a couple times that's all
like it's weird yeah they're all were
doing and sculpted Jack the Ripper's
also a girl I actually think he's a boy
lolly trap isn't he no there is actually
a trap which so many people have been
telling me about it is dressed as a girl
and I'm like people and the first
episode I made my reaction people are
like am i recon
make sure do not fall for the trap
because people have read the light novel
of the series I was like when asked to
follow came up I was like oh okay this
looks an interesting girl
and people were saying in the comments
section recon that's a boy I was like oh
[ __ ] is that the trap people were
talking about seriously it always gets
me whenever P whenever boys are dressed
as girls I just think they're girls just
oh it's not you know jack is a girl Jack
is a girl Jack is not a trap Oh pink
hair I will say Margaret is cool yeah
like as I thought that was saber like I
was like aw it's a red saber but they
like knots Mordred I was like oh [ __ ]
that's actually kind of cool like but
then I was like [ __ ] it everything after
that was lame yeah yeah like okay it's
come like a revi it needs paper but yeah
yeah yeah that kind of the other thing
yeah like devil traps and Wally just
like is just pandering to even be a
certain otaku fan
and that's what makes me think it's not
gonna end up being a good show because
never show just panders for the sake of
pandering that's a problem so now to
move on to a another anime that I I only
watch the first step to another second
what's a called here the gambling one
let's agree with that again I have
issues with I'm gonna keep watching it
because of the gray haired girl that we
see is clearly best girls so I want a
gray haired girl you mean the one with a
blue lipstick it would clearly best
Jabba me know Japanese something with
with this show and by the way for faith
Apocrypha I don't mind the animation in
terms of Studios animation is not the
problem for at all for me it's just like
I'm like the other stuff but yeah for
[ __ ] who do we again I don't get the
concept of okay so we go to the school
and we all gamble there and that's
completely okay and by the way it you
can cheat and everyone knows that
cheating is happening and everyone's
okay with that too like that that I
didn't bind to the premise not much I
also don't like the beta male
protagonist not have found that it's
like first he is dominated by one chick
and now he's gonna be dominated by the
new girl like not a fan of those types
of characters but I will keep watching
that one well your guys take I didn't
see this one so well I'd say it's later
on where you learn like the goal behind
all the gambling but at the moment it
was explained to the the count student
council president he's the one who
changed in the south the system that's
currently running and then when you meet
her later on when you me are later on
show then explain like why you know foo
to help she then puts on certain people
yeah man you'll understand oh so that's
why they did yeah I mean well yeah if it
turns out the green haired girls a trap
I'm
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ya know that there might be a nice
surprise for you but there's there's no
jobs wait have you read the miner yeah
okay I'm gonna say this right now but
the way this the Academy runs the school
itself with all the rules of the
gambling it's pretty you know savage
it's pretty cruel because a character
named subtly marry the blond-haired girl
which is on the first episode against
Jeb Ameen the thing is the way the
school runs is that if you keep on
losing
when gambling you you you owe a lot of
money to other people you are in depth
and if you keep on losing and losing
more you are being treated as a house
pet and that is what's ugly Mary is in
this situation right now people are
treating her as a house pet so if you're
not popular you get treated like [ __ ] if
you are popular you get treated like a
queen exactly like Jabba me is right now
Jeremy is like a queen she's getting
noticed by everyone she is going to be
the queen of gambling for sure yes you
could say that this is just a more
savage version of kind of the real world
yeah it's like a commentary on you know
how the real world consumerist
capitalist world actually works but in a
microcosm or a school or gambling is
like a kind of like you have investment
stocks in the real world I guess I guess
we could overthink that that way but my
thing is that the fanservice
in the show is completely contrived and
you guys know I don't hate fanservice
I like when it's done for a purpose like
with Kay Joel like with killa kill
Gurren Lagann even Code Geass like they
put it in like situations where it looks
natural but for this they have like the
camera angles just like randomly going
up the girl's skirt Jesus yeah the outro
why why that because the fencers should
somehow be like if we're looking from
the protagonists perspective like would
he see this like like with Killa Killa
like they do the battles in those
outfits for a reason
or with Keijo the whole sport revolves
around that so you understand it I don't
like when it seems so contrived it's
like oh and now here's the obligatory
fanservice and it doesn't make sense to
the plot at all is just like oh here it
is like I mean I don't mind fencers but
it kind of throws me off when I see that
type of stuff I don't know about you
guys I let the close-ups when when the
show you know creates the close-ups when
the camera zooms in to their lips and
all the stuff and they knew in action
that's really good they're very good
quality I mean gets me I'm like damn
yeah I don't like tasteless stuff like
how I was a clockwork plant it was oh
yeah yeah that was just terrible and I
know some people have a negative
reaction to the quote unquote great
faces that the girls pull as well I'm
glad I didn't watch the show I was told
so many times like like don't watch this
like everyone I know is like please
don't this is super not your show I was
like okay I don't like this stuff like
this is Jojo ends up loving in it just
like it makes him question this whole
life Jesus Christ my whole world how
about we talk about shows that
disappointed us everyone [ __ ] you I okay
man are you kidding me no it was okay
the people who disagree with me you
don't want me to do it dude I'm not
gonna be nice okay I'm not gonna be nice
to either just do it I think I think I
should talk about the good stuff go
ahead and then we can slam the show
afterwards I haven't read the manga well
when I watched the first episode people
were complaining to me during my
reaction it was very fast-paced and all
the stuff but for me like from the first
episode of nights and magic they killed
off the otaku straight like boom
innocent like really they killed him so
fast like we didn't even get to know the
real world and all the stuff we didn't
even get to know who he was and they
just killed him instantly and he got
reincarnated into this lolly boy he's
not a girl he's a boy I know yeah and I
really enjoyed I was like that was too
fast I'm like okay let's keep on going
let's see how it is so as for he got
reincarnated his dream is the pilot a
silhouette night and that was mostly
what happened in the in the first
episode then they got attacked by like
these creatures mystical creatures like
dinosaurs gorillas and all this I was
like damn okay we're getting somewhere
we'll jump to the second episode he then
goes ahead and pilots a silhouette night
and but it the way he pilots it it's
completely different from a night that
I've witnessed okay but you're recapping
the episode I've seen it like tell me
why it's good because it's so special it
stands out a lot this make a series it
sounds out it mix is mixed in with
fantasy that I just like it a lot it's
very interesting the plot anyone else
want to defend this one okay I think
come on I think you had it judging
solely off what I'm hearing I feel like
you hated it more than me so maybe I'll
go cuz I'm kind of in-between but I do
have strong feelings okay I hate yokai
stories like a lot I think they're real
dumb so that might be a tree zero and
Kona Zuba yes i 0 with a passion I think
it's a terrible show I think
Kona soup is pretty good I really like
Kona Suba because that spoofs genre that
I already don't like I feel like you're
gonna do a fantasy show do a fantasy
show I don't need some nerdy otaku being
like this is just like my video games
like I don't I don't need that [ __ ] so I
usually hate this but I will say the
main character is kind of okay I like
that he's not irritating like Subaru
like like shitball like so I I kind of
like the me I was surprised that I like
the MC so maybe that caught me off guard
and I think the idea of like night
robots is cool I think it's weird that
it's in a [ __ ] fantasy plate like
that it's clearly like they're medieval
but they have robots that aren't magic
they're robotic cuz they show you the
inside it's a [ __ ] robot so it's like
okay how can you build robots but you
live in castles that's flown a they've
always tried to combine those elements
it seems like okay escaflowne was
actually better escaflowne absolutely
good it was girl oriented like I think
that was a shoujo because the girl is a
main character and it's like a reverse
harem situation but I actually liked and
that's from the 90s and I actually liked
us Colonna
the way they did it I like that as soon
as I said Reiser oh the chats like
[ __ ] blasphemy well I personally a
lot of issues with me I don't completely
hate the whole show but I have issues
with it won't get into it now but yeah
it's it's yeah it might be REM is still
best girl bro
and then please Emilia is best girl even
super nosy
what about RAM though missing the number
one is BAE you mean yeah twinkled haired
girl
I don't Priscilla Priscilla is pretty
crazy man okay but nice and matching
clothes is dumb in height and ISA KY is
[ __ ] the only thing I like from this is
the main character I thought he was
really cool and I liked his his like
sidekicks I guess like those two kids
who like hang out with him I thought
they were like okay like the reason I
thought this was fine is because I hate
the genre but this is like okay so
that's the best I can offer is it's fine
so my problems with knights and magic is
of course and like I guess we could talk
about it in conjunction with a Sakai
of smartphone thing because it's another
piece of Kusha but like with with
Knights and magic I I thought it was
like there's no explanation whatsoever
why this guy when he's run over by car
becomes a child in another world a child
that was alive at the time and all of a
sudden he goes into that child's body
and there is no adjustment period he is
completely fine with this he's like yeah
let's do it baby woman doesn't think
about you know his former life doesn't
think about what is going on here how am
I gonna adjust it's just like Nobu let's
do it like I like that he's not a
crybaby but again like I just didn't buy
it
it was just seem to wait way too cliche
like you know you've seen one no game no
life freeze ero sort are online like how
many more can you see and then like the
the CGI animation is so bad of like the
monsters that like I can't even I can't
even guys the monsters didn't have bad
CGI that was oh I saw the bugs in the
last like as soon as they sure I'm like
are you [ __ ] for real like have you
seen the behemoth no yeah that's the CGI
that I'm talking but it's so bad man it
sticks out it's practice for me was nice
very colorful different color it was
like blue purplish and all the stuff I
mean you gotta agree with me can't just
talk about this oh no we don't I respect
you
I don't agree on about people in the
comment section definitely do agree with
me because I can definitely I've seen a
lot of who are saying that people are
agreeing the show was good so yeah I
think I got people on my side I think
it's fine to have different I think it's
it's more interesting to have different
opinions because I think if you like
generic stuff then you'll like it if you
want a pop quart like I like the other
podcast that was in talking about
seasonal anime uh this came up and I
just said if you want like a popcorn
show to watch like cuz you're bored this
is an okay one like to just be like ah
throw it on in the background whatever
like there's a term a friend of mine
used and he called it like junk food and
I think that's a really apt term because
you know it's like we all enjoyed
food and there's nothing wrong with it
obviously of course within moderation
but I mean that's just it every now and
again junk food is nice to have that's
like hey do you guys like a rate you
guys like reason hero ingress knights
and magic yeah okay but another show
that I did that feel it's just a panel
though let's talk about similar let's
talk about the e Sakai smartphone troll
yeah that's what I was about to say oh
because yeah this show actually thought
was better than Knights and magic hell
no because at least I agree at least no
Joel at least in the show there's a
justification for why he goes to another
world it's not a good one necessarily
but it's at least it's a justification
for why it actually happened so we know
something doubled the rebel nice and
magic no boobs no plot for me strikes
again thanks thanks for your support bro
um okay so sorry was that yes so the the
phone I I also thought it was kind of
interesting that you basically have keel
and roll from command as the kind of
name girls with the protagonist like
they look like them they act like them
so I guess I mean it's not original but
it's interesting is a total Opie cured
of Kondo so you know this yeah that's a
sword art online
nothing like [ __ ] Kirito he's exactly
he looks like him looks just like him
what are you talking drunk off my ass on
a stream watching this in the first
words out of my mouth is that's accurate
Oh looking [ __ ] right there that
was the first word that might not very
cute oh absolutely I mean no Kirito is
more serious this guy is like he could
be more serious with a lorry identical
it their appearance like I know their
appearance yeah that's what I'm saying
they look I definitely the character
design and that's just it felt like an
absolute clone of him but it's the fact
of how the character you could base
they plug into him in terms of being a
blank slate I mean obviously there are
differences in terms of the character
differences in terms of personality and
so forth but yeah rather how the
audience themselves can attach
themselves
yeah the character like this dude is
like cutie toes at least like a badass
which is nice things like that's it
that's his characters
I am badass you're like a scary thought
you are badass uh this guy is just
[ __ ] worthless like I again I hate he
Sakai I watch this because I got drunk
and decided to do a live reaction which
I almost never do and I was like let's I
think I'd like I had to delete it
because I ended up getting really
hammered and I just played anime music
at the end but I just titled it like
this shop is probably [ __ ] so let's
watch it and I was surprised with how
much I actually like it's bad but I had
fun with it because it doesn't really
take itself super serious which I like
here's what I'm gonna say about I said
how smartphone mm-hmm I was so excited
for it like first time I got announced I
was the trailer was like this looks
interesting it could be like another
funny kind of Suba parody yeah like yeah
let's do this first episode let's get
into this
I see the main character and I straight
away judge them ok he is plaintiffs [ __ ]
and he was so like he wasn't panicking
it was like okay I'm then what's going
on he was like he sounds so confident
now he met God no to another world what
would you like in that another world and
he was like okay I want my phone I'm
gonna use my phone as like uh so then he
got transported he uses phone met a
bunch of lollies and he just introduced
like [ __ ] ice creams them what he
meant like what he knows how to use all
six elements of magic and I was like is
that it that was it thanks yeah that was
he was doused em the sick he can just
use the magic so easy I was like idiot
all wheeled in a counter is to that I
actually went in the opposite that you
did recon I looked at it read the
description I'm like oh this is gonna be
terrible
this sounds dreary
bland and bullying the same cuz I mean
it's just it's like oh hey it's a
fantasy show we're a modern kid gets a
feedback in the past and he's got a cell
phone
I didn't you know it's almost like Sakai
is really stupid or something yeah like
um no no Oda Nobunaga they did something
similar that where the guy had his cell
phone with him and he used and made it
noise he was able to distract soldier I
mean it's been done before you know who
cares but I you know believe it or not I
actually didn't mind I don't think it's
good but I didn't mind the fact that at
least they explained it God was like hey
yeah um I killed you be there oh sorry
about that oh you know that's okay
you're really taking this calmly I my
grandfather just talking you know except
things that happen in life is like
comets that's really cool and it's just
yeah it's just you know it's like eons
that's all good hey you know I
appreciate and you know just want my
cell phone we can't contact anyone you
know okay it's any of these combats up
you know of course yeah anyone would be
freaking out but it's so the calmness is
a little too extreme but it's like at
the same time his openness makes sense
like gods like hey yo I'm gonna give you
a stat boost
I shouldn't everything so where the
characters are like um most people
generally at best can use three elements
and that's considered really good you
can use all six what are you like what
are you he's a god they explain why I
carry toes a badass in the game it
doesn't make it any more than like less
steel exactly I appreciate the fact
though that it's they try to at least
play and that there's actually like a
God that you know is able to bestow
these things so the this omnipotent
being bestows this character is stuff
now obviously of course where it goes
from there I mean it's it's pretty
standard generic fare there isn't my
scream these girls are probably gonna
fall over him he's probably gonna meet
other girls as well he's building an
errand party yes so what but I didn't
actually mind the first episode that
much I was entertained at least silently
it's good though it was chilling I don't
say it was a chill up so I'm not too bad
I think chill is the perfect yeah cuz
again I hate this [ __ ] like so I try to
have fun I tried to have fun with it and
it's it's the kind of show where like it
doesn't take itself so
like it's like this is stupid let's have
some fun and they just kind of have fun
I do like the magic system I just wish
she wasn't like God Tyr at it right away
yeah yeah strikes again donate two
pounds to say no full no means no life
he's a modern kid he needed to have his
phone I gotta have my phone what is the
[ __ ] water the phone I don't actually
have a problem with that because I feel
like it's a cool concept to be able to
be in a fantasy world and actually in
some way interact with the real world
see what's going on in the real world I
think that's a unique twist that could
be used well in the world but it could
be but is it human eyes him though like
Animax said it's a good way for him to
keep in touch with the old world and
it's just it does establish an element
of being a human being like you're
transported to someplace else
yeah you are gonna want to attach
yourself to those things that you're
familiar with the only limit is like
that so I like that but I wish he kept
like anything else I'm like really a
[ __ ] phone like not a memento of your
grandfather if the point of the show but
all it serves is that like super many
voices mother exactly yeah this phone is
my grandfather anything I would have
taken that because it's like all they do
all they use the phone for us to take
selfies as like the like buffer between
commercials that's all I use it for the
only good thing they use that phone for
that episode was just to navigate his
way to town and yeah teach them about
ice crumb that was it that was Google so
Google Maps it exists in the same
where's the service provider what's
going on God did it created the service
for him he got yeah go they explained
the battery that he can recharge the
battery through magic but it's like the
service provider it's like hey you know
how good is my coverage is right here is
God set up a battle plan for him I know
we'll see we'll see y'all
I'm dropping this a balloon yeah it was
fun havin fun
give it three episodes yeah I give up
better might get worse so one that I
actually thought could be good is the
Vatican kissaki yeah miracle yeah
endurance or whatever that I thought it
was very creepy and in an interesting
way and like you knew there was a lot
going on there and that it could be
interesting it could also go just like
the problem is that I don't see any
characters right now that I would really
like and be able to attach myself to
maybe they have that changes so we'll
see how it goes how they develop the
characters but I think that that could
potentially be a good kind of for a
psychological anime what do you guys
think I mean I'm not into mystery that
much i watched the first episode but
then it got to a point where i was
getting bored there wasn't really too
much happening i know it's a mystery a
lot of yeah i'm talked about a lot it
wasn't that appealing to me so that's
why i'm like i don't know whether I
should continue I don't know whether I
should drop it but I'm still gonna give
it a three Episode test but the plot is
the main reason why I'm getting bored of
it mister I this is like the one show
that I was like like like but just
before the podcast I was like have I
watched everything yeah oh [ __ ] and this
was the one I forgot so I was like [ __ ]
cuz like I'm not to tell too much about
myself but I have an uncle who's a
priest
right so like I'm very tied to this kind
of thing like Orthodox Catholic Romanian
don't be like let's watch Castlevania
like buddy boy yeah you'll be happy
about that
my ice is like why am I being fertilized
by faith being portrayed as being dicks
we actually watched young Pope together
so that was fun uh-huh anyway this I
wanted to watch this cuz it sounds
interesting
and I've heard people say it's
interesting I've also heard like people
side with recon saying it's very dull so
I don't know we'll see I think it sounds
cool that's that's all I've got on that
yeah like it's not a battle
Shonen yeah I like that yeah I think it
sorry I mean it looks interesting
because I mean there's the mystery
itself just going on but then there also
seems to be like some kind of political
agenda within the church itself as well
yeah yeah there's something talked about
and you're like oh but you see a scene
and you're like oh does that guy and it
seems as soon as someone wants to
mention it there sounds yeah I mean so
it's that okay so what are they hiding
that or covering that up for I mean why
did I want to be so hush about it so
yeah I think that there's there's a lot
more going on in it but I guess those
who just want boobs in action they're
gonna get nothing from this series
because the series a about that one
animate that really I I'm most hopeful
about right now is made in abyss thought
dude good good you know you guys know
that castle on the sky is one of my
favorite anime a movies and this is very
much influenced by castle in the sky
like you could tell by the animation
like just like the designs my one
drawback is that I don't know why the
characters are so kawaii looking like
now your TV style oh my god he's almost
like why are you doing this and like
that's what I'm afraid is gonna end up
being too much fan pandering it's kind
of distracting but otherwise this is
definitely a show that I'm most hopeful
about it looks like an interesting world
it like I said it's it the animation is
great like the setup was interesting so
I'm hopeful yeah for me it's between
this and token ranbu for like top like
my favorite of the season I still watch
token ranbu
I love it you might not like has a lot
of like the male fan service for the
girls as well like when you meet with
the guys and stuff it seems like yeah
that guy looks a bit too feminine he's a
little young guy he looks a bit too
feminine well they have their moments
like okay how's it going don't mind me
just eatin my rice
like it's a little yeah yeah yeah they
got to go to different light boxes that
you know they got the big bro type of
guy they got the lower innocent naive
guy they got like the the bossy leader
kind of guy they got the stoic kind of
guy yeah and yeah just take all the
boxes all of the guys that what's that
one Sekai blast
yeah that's another one ways you know
guys for the mail you can't watch that
blast
yeah you can't watch that that's a 40
season yeah so if you haven't watched
the others you can't watch that it's
technically it's a sequel actually yes
here it doesn't advertise itself as a
sequel yeah I've clicked on it on any
chart and yes checked if there was a
prequels like no okay so what is it well
people did tell me that this is the
fourth season so if you haven't watched
the others you can't watch this one so I
was like okay I can't watch it yeah I
don't talk too much about token ranbu
because like I'm sure we'll get to that
later like I want to say like made of
this [ __ ] awesome like I it was
between this and metallic like this in
token ranbu
and for the longest time like no nobody
was touching token ranbu but this show
was like one of the last times I watched
this feels like it was made for me cuz
I'm like I loved I loved fantasy series
like it's got fantasy
I like big monster hunter fan it's got
monsters like robot kid I loved Megaman
oh yeah that'd make a Mac with like
extendable arms because the thing is I
love the character design I don't have a
problem with them being kawaii it's a
nice it's nice to change things around
not always being the same thing with a
regular characters nice to have chibi
style it's cute the thing is what mostly
interested me is the plot and the story
and the setting of course where it takes
place
discovering the underground of this I'm
like wow mystical creatures down there
relics this is a great adventure series
this could really brighten up the season
and trust me
I'm gonna save it I'm gonna say this
right now but this could
everything this season for me made it of
us is like crazy good yeah I have to
agree with you on something recon so
that's good what is it this is it this
is made in a bit yeah it's really good
I'm really liking it what I'm doing with
it so far obviously I don't talk too
much about it because I'm well into the
manga and I could spoil the crap out of
it
don't do that myself read a lot of manga
to eat them watch it's just a lot more
entertaining you get a lot more out of
the story
you see if I'm watching them now I only
got to watch one episode if I'm reading
the manga now I've done like what 50
chapters also yeah I mean so yeah but um
yeah we've we've made an abyss I can say
that it's I love how I mean I don't mind
the whole cute factor because they are
young yeah I mean they are little kids
so it's fine it's not like you know
where you get the lollies mum
you know she's like 40 some yeah she's
like [ __ ] 2 foot something yeah I
mean it's no these are actual kids so
it's fine that they look like kids I
mean the adults don't look like [ __ ]
adults yeah you know monsters are great
there's some really interesting monsters
later on
I like the science that they're gonna
put into it because it's kind of akin to
the band's you know deep-sea diving kind
of thing but yeah got in this abyss
thing and it yeah me but they can
explain that more probably within the
next episode actually and yeah it's just
like like the way it looks in it you
expect something like a Ghibli movie you
know this guy for sure it goes so deep
though like funny enough as they go
deeper the story gets deeper yeah my son
you just sound dirty
so the cheaper in this is gonna get
really deep into it yes I'm coming up
this is gonna get dark
I have really dark really dark I can't
okay
like as a like in reality I hate kids
like I think I I hate wall I hate all
that [ __ ] I don't like kids in general I
think kids are loud annoying and
obnoxious but the kids in this are like
adorable and I'm like I will protect
these kids hey these kids are great I
love that I just saw the way they're all
gonna get slaughtered by which makes me
worried yeah probably ever children
watching tomorrow don't worry I still
love you I still love you even if I
don't cou dad I love you keep watching
okay kids though they don't have parents
they are all in an orphanage and I like
how they are assigned tasks by the by
the adults on what they need to do but
however the main character she wants to
do a lot more she doesn't want to do the
tasks that the adults are assigning her
to do she wants to go deeper and explore
the abyss my god I'm sorry you like if
you like Rand Coffey we got a hundred
likes for their last week's let's see if
we can beat that this week I gave you a
dislike by the way just like there's so
many minutes I'm just not interested in
that I don't like you know at this point
I don't know if I'll end up giving him a
shot if people convinced me like soullow
convinced me to read my hero academia
manga but out south he did and now I'm
much more like into the show that I was
into just the show because the manga but
ballroom I have no interest right now in
watching it i yeah dog I talk about dive
I'm gonna say this right now I I feel so
sorry for the people who thought that
dive was gonna be the next free that's
really enough like yeah this is the next
free [ __ ] free is a fire too
awesome show like I'm
month of free on my channel right now I
love free free is great yes this ain't
no free this is trash it is about
literally boys dining it's not about
swimming it is so about boys just jump
right people Board and their judges
diving I remember ty zhing yeah like
three actually has like characters and
story and it's interesting and the
characters relationships to each other
like evolved the plot it's [ __ ]
interesting and the edits done by Keo a
nice oh it looks beautiful this is
[ __ ] garbage like I'm sorry but dive
is the worst thing I've seen all season
like socks
Jesus I remember sign are you telling me
hey recon why don't you react to dive
and judge the character is diving
remember you told me that sign be funny
actually and I was like no I really I
don't really want to judge the them just
diving into the pool I mean their goal
is to go to the Olympics and just dive
and dive and dive and exactly it's just
it's so boring
there's nothing seconds to get from the
board to the water yeah I I should have
dropped it like like halfway drawing I
don't know I was a bad first episode it
was terrible no I mean I should have
stopped watching while I was watching
like I was like this is bad I finished
the first episode I'm like I could have
dropped that like a minute in I knew
exactly what is gonna be the whole way
through oh good yeah Tolson a and not
sue for complementing the channel thank
you guys so much for your kind words
we love you all so how many Yuri fans
enjoyed skirt Nonaka oh my god dude I
didn't watch it I was told what happened
I'm like to put the [ __ ]
think I think the big the big the big
girl I think it said what was a boy I
think it's a trap everything they may
confirm that but Ryo isn't Mac man who
dresses like a lady he dresses like a
lady and then he has some nice hottie
times at the bathroom with her gets her
naked it just sits on the toilet seat
and I was like wow magic does animate it
so you know this is a juror what do you
think about Nexus or trap the one with
the two girls cheating on their
boyfriends the one where the
black-haired girl rapes the blonde yeah
that was great
and it's a short - it's not it's a short
it's okay but not that great it's pretty
good with this this season which
actually have no interest in after
watching it because it seems like the
director was on LSD or something is that
18f Katie I knew so bad though with you
mainly key because that's
18f like that's exactly yeah I would
agree with you on there yeah like I
don't know I mean if it feels stretched
out like a single-story stretched out
over like say three four episodes the
maybe there could be some kind of sense
in it but as it's as it seems it's gonna
be like each episode is a single story
it's not really much time to develop as
such and it's just gonna be a weird
episode after we RepA sowed with a very
very short conclusion yeah yeah if you
know I wanted my last ever garden but I
couldn't find it anymore
that's coming out January it's January
oh yeah somebody take out the guys who
run mal in the balls for that by the way
it's a mouth that's why yeah yeah it
looks great but it's coming out January
same like ankle fate ankle yeah
yes same same thing as they released it
at [ __ ] what is it Anime Expo I guess
like they show people like the first
episode I guess of like whatever show
and so the rest of us are like so it
aired this season but we don't get to
see it but it aired this like it's
[ __ ] weird what about a whole girl
that is hilarious banana girl yeah that
was I hated that show kidding me cyanide
funny
the monkeys function to the show same
like the zoo a do a children I want to
pitch like a ho girl or whatever it's
called okay yeah okay
girl yeah you you want to watch nine
minutes of some dude be teased the [ __ ]
out of a girl yeah like that bit it is
like every five seconds I was like
exactly and then does the suplex
he's German suplexes her she is okay
I usually agreed with cyanide I'm gonna
disagree on this only because it is
funny like that girl is an idiot but
they play it up for Laughs there's
another character who's a total idiot I
don't want to say the name cuz the chat
will [ __ ] massacre me but there's a
show that aired that I can't stand
because the emcee is so stupid
in this the main character is supposed
to be I know who you are I know I know I
don't wanna say I'm not gonna say I know
who you people will be mad I'm not gonna
say no but the MCMC in this is supposed
to be dumb and that's the joke so I'm
fine with it here and she is like oh my
god yeah even though markers of yeah
even even her mom's like Jesus
his mom is always like please take care
of her because marry her one day please
I love this like never matter I am never
gonna marry this girl I actually kind of
like this show there's a lot of great
things in there but my problem is that
generally slapstick can be quite
humorous I mean obviously Three Stooges
from years gone past even current era
slapstick will always generally have
some form of humor in it the problem is
that it ceases being slapstick and
becomes abuse he straight up yeah yeah
literally a piece of [ __ ] to her and
he's constantly insulting her he's like
I mean he's literally beating the [ __ ]
out of her to where she goes flying and
she what you're essentially being dumb
she says something stupid and he like
literally just shoryuken like if this is
a real show like if this was animated if
this was real I'd be mortified
no no but one minute woman sign ID it's
okay though when a tsundere female does
not to AM L know how could Korea keep
doing that even girls Bravo two I mean
what's girls bro oh god yeah [ __ ]
girls Bravo that's another thing but no
it's just this I'm generally not a fan
of it because abuse to me is not good
writing it's not good storytelling it
doesn't develop the character right yeah
likeable character who responds
aggressively with violence to someone
and its really obvious the show is gonna
pair them up together and it basically
makes her place stand as if you're
supposed to be idiots let the guy take
care of you and do everything it
basically creates a character that comes
across very much as an archaic archetype
that's expected for the female to be
there done they're stupid
they're basically supposed to have kids
stay at home let the man do everything
he's supposed to take care of you it is
yeah currently it's salting for that
reason cuz the thing is it's just it's
one thing to be stupid but it's like
they treat her that he has to take care
of her and he abuses her doesn't like
her but he still does it yeah we're out
there's some funny little funny
there but the show expands upon this and
that becomes the joke yes one thing
abuse repeat scene and it's just it's ad
nauseam even in 13 minutes for one
episode it's an excess it's it's
literally the entire show is like again
I it's funny because it's animated if
they actually but the more like when you
pointed out it's like yeah it is kind of
[ __ ] up like it's my problem with NTR
is like everyone's like it's hot I'm
like she [ __ ] raped her like it's
like just be like you're right like just
because it's animated it doesn't make it
like less [ __ ] wrong it's a like it's
just you know chilly like so serious man
but I mean that's the thing is it's just
it's it's a slippery slope dude like
it's not letting some shits live you
they got it like it's not yeah but I
will say [ __ ] it's kind of funny like
that shoulder you can't make me laugh
and I apologize but they kept doing it
and to the point where another girl is
crying because he's so aggressive and
that's like if it had been like a
cutaway like in Full Metal Alchemist
when somebody like punches Edie into the
stratosphere right like he goes away but
then they cut back and he's right there
like it was clearly like an off like a
just a joke like it like a gag and this
like he punches her she goes flying and
then they carry out the scene when she
has like a bruise and she's like against
the wall it's kind of [ __ ] up it's
pretty like it's pretty hardcore and she
just she's like oh like what did she say
like what she's got like she says
something about like a banana this show
doesn't want you to beat his wife who's
he kicks the [ __ ] out of her and I'm
like why she's charming like she's just
stupid like I kind of like her know the
fact that she gets 0 every time that's
why it's one for character to blast off
like Team Rocket or Jack but something
that's over the top it's one thing but
it's like she's constantly being abused
and it
it's more of less not in a response its
lashing out to how she is the person
which I mean strikes me as I'm like this
guy's gonna [ __ ] beat his kids and
his wife he gets married it's like she
talks to the student council president
no she starts acting like an idiot right
she's like yeah response to it that
makes sense he thought I'm fine with
that that was [ __ ] up too because he
punches her and she goes flying into a
railing I have an interesting theory is
that when he when he gets to marry her
and they had these kids yeah I'm pretty
sure it he is gonna marry her they're
gonna have kids and then he's gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of the kids because the
kids are also dumb they're gonna get 0
on every test we're gonna fail school
they're gonna do bad and like the crap
no way no I hope he hooks up with the
other girl because I don't accept this
there's a show that actually the whole
dumb girl thing right was Nodame
cantabile but she's also like a pianist
and then the guy that did she's Chiaki I
think his name is sempai like pushing
her away kind of thing but he's all I
got you think so I thought that showed
the duck that may was finally I know
we'll talk about Nodame cantabile Dom a
is funny like she she was crazy like cuz
this music thing Anna Anna obviously
with all music it has it set tempo and
stuff in it but then she would like kind
of like zone out and going to our own
mind to start going at our own tempo and
a lot of people couldn't keep up but a
lot of musician like teachers were
amazed at it because she was getting the
notes correct but she was going so
bloody fast yeah I mean but she would do
things that if she heard a piece of
music Chucky's senpai did for example
which sounded amazing you then dedicate
herself to repeating that performance
for days on end and enough to short turn
up is his house cuz she lives right next
door
your terrible house
hair all messy her clothes thinking
could she be washed or not and she sat
on that piano the whole time in it then
off the huge is like four seven to the
barking stuff then they will make her
some food will give it to her any who
say go on eat it should be like now I'm
not eating so then he'll pin her head
back you know get the spoons doubling
the food into her mouth eight it was you
know it was humorous you know with her
stupidity but it's like it was nice
because you saw how she slowly won him
over
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I I'm glad we had this conversation
because Simon I just made me go like
you're a bad person
come on oh my god talk about let's talk
about one more anime than Brad Pitt
uncle can we talk about yoga class movie
Lee I didn't see that one yeah what's
the meaning I did not either I didn't
want you have seen it okay I'll check it
check it out it's you know you don't
want to talk about it's the cover where
everyone is dressed in their red school
uniform it's oh the lurch one yeah we're
okay yeah I'm gonna check it out yeah
what'swhat's the like what's the biggest
on mal right now I think it's I honestly
think it's [ __ ] hajimeta Noel oh no
because it won't go in those three
craters yeah that's that doesn't count
when I get four counts it's like they
could be talking about my hero academia
cuz I love that show yeah yeah
definitely
new respect for me creators I'm seeing
like some of these Sakai Eve yeah I I
apologize for ever making fun of real
creators after seeing some of the [ __ ] I
see like okay fair enough I see some
stuff I have seen things there is a show
that still didn't come out yet that I'm
excited for it's the reflection wave one
coming out eight days that's a mistake
yeah
let Stanley like as a comic book nerd
when I saw that I was like [ __ ] yes like
stand all waiting for it
we done here oh man it's yeah yeah no
it's yes it's it's action so I'm excited
I don't know that's the only one that um
yet need to stand Stan Lee is an expert
at making characters
I think Stan's story's kind of fall
apart like I love Stan but like his
expertise is making characters so if he
makes the characters and then kind of
lets like the team make the story it'll
be great
I mean he Roman was alright but I don't
know like who wrote that story yeah I
mean yeah okay
well there was a manga to that he was
involved with solely you probably know
it I can't remember the name but he was
involved with the manga with someone
else
hmm that sounds I I can't I know you're
talking about but I can't remember yeah
yeah cut cut
Carol Kui doji Ultimo yes there we go
yes that's the one Ultimo yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the one yeah she's an odd
duck yeah hello Stan you guys watched
your Chi apartment I did yeah good show
surprised yeah it's like do you like
mushishi or if mushi she was like
ridiculous and happened in an apartment
building instead of the forest maca
Lydia yeah that's literally the show
funny name
Aki name she's best girl within the
series Oh - totally she's so
good-looking
well she's like she's cool cuz she's
like she's an exorcist right and her job
has to sit like she has to go to the
hospital every time because I'm super
high all the time and I'm like night
shifts of the hospital is like the
creepiest thing and really scares me cuz
you you think like if you're at a night
shift at a hospital you're like in an
abandoned hospital and something's gonna
happen to you I for the last year and a
half I worked the night shift at at a
dog hotel so it was me by myself for ten
hours alone and every so often a dog
would growl at me and that is [ __ ]
terrifying
dog hotel mystery
dog hotel best admit 2017 oh I know what
like cat cafes and buffers well this is
like like like if you're going out of
town you leave your dog with these
people that's that's all it is
I wish it was cool we're like you get to
eat like like eat and drink coffee like
yeah whatever and drink coffee and hang
out with dogs that's not what this what
about soccer corner Alpine you guys
watch that yeah that was actually
interesting episodes until I can really
make my mind up about it's about the
Ottoman Empire and it's really
interesting about them yeah yeah I like
the main character what I did I didn't
like him nah no one not woman and he
just kind of shied away from it like
like oh no but people were complaining
about about the manga because during
that first episode when he fought
against that thief people were saying
that they could they kind of skipped on
a lot during that fight because the
manga was a little bit more rude a
little bit more bloody but in the
animates it's completely different so
they kind of skipped on that which I
wanted to see what it would be what it
was pretty brutal but I thought the
episode was good I mean however a lot of
people did complain I don't know why did
did we talk about centaur life yet like
with monster Musume and stuff it's just
like another one of those and I got
interested in that shows [ __ ] good
dude like it's actually like it's not
cool or not most of us may I swear like
this this show is like it actually goes
into it's like Lauren like humanity
didn't descent for monkeys they
descended from like lizards and like
[ __ ] like that like it's act it's I'm
doing a shitty job at describing it but
it's actually like like just watch first
episode it's generally recommend the
Centaur thing cuz I was thinking it was
just one of those no it's good like
holding there we go did not see that
coming yeah well that's it like this
has been the season of like that show
sounds stutely like everything that I
usually hate for some reason the seasons
be like no but it's funny though Mike
okay there was a mist out from the manga
door with that would that send to one I
liked that they felt like a world like
we're like certain monsters couldn't do
certain things because it was like
against the law and I'm like oh [ __ ]
that's cool and like the way they
explained like where monsters came from
it was [ __ ] really fast the manga
soul yeah yeah yeah the first the first
episode was different and I thought that
maybe it will be different than actually
gonna show this but I'm guessing they
sensitive because whatever time their
area or whatever but the first episode
started off with central girl and her
friends on a train and there was a angel
boy that was there and he was trying to
answer all right you want to give her a
letter and she went off she was scared
so then her friends go with her you know
eventually at the end of the day they
got the gold to her house and stuff okay
so we would you know what what was the
problem right
why what did you run off and stuff so
then she talks about oh well you should
know that the fact of you know I think
it's like 1 in 6 there's a chance that
you're a baby that you have with an
angel or central with an angel would
come out deformed in it stuff and then
had one of them's like oh yeah but you
know the you know the government is
ready set up like subsidies for that to
you know cover expenses and things like
that if that was to occur yeah I mean
and then after she then talks about like
this trip did she school trip she went
on when she was young and there was a
cow there and the cow had it's like
back-end to them and stuff and one of
the little angel kids it was with her
pointing to the like the cows private
area and was like oh that's like yours
boys hurts like like well yeah she's
funny over it I can't no this is why
they did them yeah after the friends are
like
okay well we'll show each other us so Oh
No
comfortable with it yeah I mean and they
end up doing that
so obviously it's like yeah okay yeah
now I get it
you know I mean and yeah yeah cause the
things like that that's why so sense and
like chapters and stuff will probably
just be that completely skipped you
probably posted yeah there's more like I
don't feel kind of hold on okay Jojo yes
I'll make you a deal
okay I will watch sent our girl and you
watch sent our girl it fine yeah I'll do
it and I'll stream it to there you go
okay fine tell me when you're streaming
I'll stream it sometime tomorrow also
but no one no one touch green haired
girl she's mine so I'll take the one in
the mosque does does the bat girl hook
up with the centaur girl because they're
[ __ ] adorable
no spoilers what I'm not saying anything
I'm just saying those two are cute
together and I like hold hands and go to
coffee that we missed it is not a model
with some BOTS who fastest finger first
yes a quiz game show it's surprisingly
it's good enjoyable really enjoyable
yes say that sounded yeah I wouldn't
even gain especially come on
like fastest finger first is like who's
enrolled in school he doesn't really
stand out blends in he wants to find a
way to kind of stand out a bit more but
doesn't really excel at anything but she
reads a lot so he's got this really fast
quality of knowledge and
for just fainting this quiz thing but
it's really timid but he's able to do it
and people really surprise and that it's
kind of builds from there after the
first episode so however there is a flaw
within this series because a certain
character Fukami the female protagonist
of the show her voice actor didn't do a
very good job
I was surprised first time actually
heard the voice acting for her it did
not match her at all I was pretty
disappointed but that is not gonna stop
me from watching this series so you
might if you people who haven't watched
it you might notice it it's really
noticeable straight away like hey that
voice is pretty surprising on it it is a
little different but I mean I didn't
mind selling Maya too much cuz you know
but like you said it and still think she
does a good job but yeah it's when you
see the character and you hear or speak
to don't necessarily mesh but I mean
that's the thing with real life it sees
someone your speaker like did not expect
that yeah fun fact I 9 is actually a 6
foot 8 bodybuilder even lift you need to
show me that body boy
just so you know you lost me a timid guy
cyanine that's where you lost me that
he's not a coward per se which is kinda
like I don't know how later episodes
will be but it's not the whole I mustn't
run away type thing it's 0 days cuz it's
the same [ __ ] guy like only he
doesn't suck like that's the difference
the same like typical Shonen archetype
guy yeah he's fine like he's just yeah
like you said just the typical Shonen
whatever
and by the way shoutout for jiggy
software or software I'm guessing oh
yeah yeah I figured we're talking about
anime so I'm good we have to wrap this
up guys getting hairy yes I appreciate
you all coming here and I know we can't
get to all of them and there's too many
but I think this was like good
productive time I had a few anime now
that have to actually check out like the
descent or one
and which one other ones really please
watch it the first one that was so
demented oh god you better know golly
yeah yeah alright so before we go though
I want to go to all you guys and so you
can tell the people who you are and what
you do and of course thanks for running
the Chad who was here with us and then
with a slimy was watching after-the-fact
sign ID you first
well someone mentioned Akashic records
that was last season Natsu fired up
we're talking about summer 2017
my name is Sinai Blizzard aka table [ __ ]
um I just sit around because I'm a table
sadly I can't really do anything I'm
really sorry about the Nina thing yeah
we had a whole thing on the meat we're
over it we're over it we had a whole Red
Cafe that was a lot of it was about the
whole mean of thing is I've talked about
this already kay you know I'm sorry I'm
sorry I wrote it up you should be no I
I've made my peace with that you know
it's a part of my life now it's a part
of who I am I accept that so you're
gonna be in season 3 I'm I was supposed
to be I was supposed to be a main
character but I don't know how that's
gonna go you know we're gonna see here I
was supposed to get a really big role
but um I really hope so
issues happen in terms of the contract
negotiating so we'll see though either
we will let you know here on this
channel first exactly yes
who does the casting call for table [ __ ]
is in we will let you know don't put a
problem are you done with your outro I
am that is that is the outro thank you
so much ah now to recon anim recon
please okay you go job do you hey my
name is Jojo from the channel Jojo talks
too much I do a show called Ana minutes
which some of you have heard of I
suppose and right now on the channel I'm
doing a thing called free month where I
about free iwatobi swim club the first
season a show that I love a lot and I'm
doing that on the channel right now it's
cool if you like free that's the thing
if not then maybe subscribe to me after
three months is over I've lost a couple
people but yeah that's that's what I'm
doing
yep nice sounds good and links are in
the description to all the channels guys
so you can check that out soul maka to
you hey everybody's me so market you
know me I'm not sure though jenna is and
you can catch me on Animax discord and
may I pose this code link should be in
the video or in the description always
in all description yeah so yeah you guys
can catch me there if you want to speak
with me more I'll talk about my manga
mainly but I do have a lot of experience
with animes or so cut you guys there
yeah and uh this Court is always fun
guys we can continue the discussion
there afterwards so join us and finally
recon what's up guys my the dis recon
here I do
aka havoc no Picou aka recon no pico I
do them reactions seasonal reactions
every single [ __ ] day I do top
10 lists which is getting a lot popular
that's what's getting my channel a lot
more notice so yeah go ahead subscribe
if you want to and I have a crush them
cyanide and I love you all so yeah
wow we just got a crush on cyanide the
guy that loves female itchy anime also
likes a table we're all ladies and
gentlemen anime fans
you're never gonna figure them out
alright yeah thank you again guys for
being our guests will be back again next
week 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time ranked
our fake crushing it
thanks everyone in the chad you were
amazing and active and awesome drop a
like let's see we can get this to 100
Mike's by next week and until next time
see us bass
boys wall